moving on former president trump has
been ordered to answer questions under
oath as part of a fraud investigation
into his company a new york judge ruled
yesterday that the former president
ivanka trump and donald trump jr must
obey the subpoena from new york attorney
general leticia james she is considering
a lawsuit against the trump organization
one of several legal challenges to the
former president senior investigative
correspondent catherine harris is
following this probe catherine good
morning well good morning nade the
judge's order opens the door to
depositions by former president trump
and his two eldest children within 21
days if it's upheld the eight-page
ruling means new york state attorney
general leticia james could ask trump
ivanka and don jr about their business
practices as part of a civil probe james
has accused the trump organization of
using fraudulent or misleading practices
to get loans and tax benefits during a
contentious virtual hearing yesterday
the trump's attorneys accused james who
is a democrat a prosecutorial misconduct
and political bias and her investigation
as an effort to pave the way for
possible criminal charges in a separate
investigation which he is also involved
in trump and his two children could
invoke their fifth amendment rights as
eric trump has done previously but their
lawyers argued yesterday that refusing
to talk to avoid self-incrimination
could be used against them in a parallel
criminal probe trump's lawyers have
indicated they would appeal and that
could delay or even derail the
depositions legal experts told cbs news
ignoring a valid order from the court is
exceedingly rare the individual can be
held in contempt and face possible jail
time vlad
all right catherine thank you very much